ça ressemble à une bonne nouvelle quatre
buza 1 pour l'équipe de France cette
victoire que viennent de nous proposer
les Bleus le match n'est pas tout à fait
fini merci de nous rejoindre sur le
Figaro.fr sur Youtube nous sommes en
direct pour débriefer ce premier match
de l'équipe de France au Qatar dans
cette Coupe du Monde 2022 autour de moi
Yves très hard bonjour bonsoir bonsoir
bon il reste quelques secondes on est
satisfait quatre butins c'est une
excellente nouvelle on est surtout
satisfait de la seconde période parce
que la première nous avait quand même
laissé quelques petits doutes
l'ouverture du score australienne 20
premières minutes française
très poussif très
balbutiante et puis et puis une seconde
période totalement maîtrisée des
Australiens qu'on n'a pas vu qui ont pas
eu la moindre occasion c'est c'est
vraiment c'est du très très bon très
très bon travail c'est une très bonne
entame il y a encore des choses à revoir
en défense je pense que Didier Deschamps
fera lui aussi son petit débriefing
demain à l'abri des regards vous voyez
les équipes les supporters qui sortent
du stade alors c'est pas le bon score à
droite je préviens en régie c'est bien 4
buts on va mettre à jour tout ça
Yves bon vous êtes content vous nous
aviez dit avant le match toujours
difficile de rentrer dans la compétition
10 minutes difficile et puis après ça
déroulé alors là c'est pas le match
entier qui a été difficile comme il y a
4 ans contre la même équipe australienne
mais c'est vrai que on a eu un petit peu
peur au début c'est des Australiens qui
ont ouvert le score avec un très beau
but il faut le dire et puis l'erreur de
défense française et puis après bon bah
on a on a réussi à rattraper à rattraper
ce cette
erreur défensive et puis à s'installer
dans le match les Français n'ont pas
perdu leur sang-froid surtout ils ont
été sur de même et je dirais qu'après
ils ont déroulé on a eu une première
mi-temps où ils ont ils ont partie de
cette première mi-temps avec
un score de 2-1 et puis la deuxième
mi-temps c'était
l'équipe australienne n'a quasiment pas
existé et là on a vu une grosse
différence de niveau qui était quasiment
on pouvait dire un match comme un match
d'entraînement pour les Français Cindy
votre première réaction et puis
évidemment vous réagissez sur YouTube
sur Le Figaro.fr je vais prendre toutes
vos réactions on en parle on est allé
une petite heure ensemble les autres
membres du service des sports nous
rejoindrons et on va dans un instant
avec Vincent roseron qui est devant le
stade Cindy votre première réaction
l'Australie est chaos la question que je
me pose maintenant c'est de savoir
est-ce que vraiment Didier Deschamps va
faire venir banane je voulais dire parce
que effectivement ou pas mécano on voit
qu'il est très vertical et il est connu
pour ça il casse les lignes Konaté là on
l'a vu vers la fin du match avec une
passeport Griezmann qui vraiment arrive
à s'emposser petit à petit en équipe de
France après évidemment on connaît des
choses c'est qu'il tient à ces cadres
mais je pourrais voir l'équipe de France
continuait sur cette lancée avec ses
défauts là
elle n'aura pas les mêmes oppositions
aussi je pense qu'avec le Danemark ça
sera quand même autrement plus musclé et
c'est là le vrai test ça sera là c'est
samedi le grand match ça sera samedi là
c'était un match test je dirais sur le
plan psychologique mais sur le plan
purement footballistique je sais pas ce
qu'on pense Cédric mais c'est ça sera
c'est vraiment ça bique ça va se passer
du groupe d'autant plus maintenant que
qui a pu Paul Pogba notamment donc c'est
c'est non non je pense que après par
contre il va y avoir un mal de crâne
sans doute au vu du match pour Didier
Deschamps pour savoir entre ou pas
mécano et Konaté lequel mettre à côté de
Varane on sait que Didier aime beaucoup
Konaté mais j'ai trouvé ou pas mécano
très convaincant on va rentrer dans tous
ces débats
tactique je sens que vous avez très
envie d'y aller vous voyez le classement
déjà avec la France donc il prend la
tête de ce groupe vous voyez le score 4
bus à 1 oui quelques photos du match je
salue amine je salue twenty firs century
remis le doPi David Jay qui dit bravo à
notre Giroud et oui c'est peut-être le
fait du match il devient comme meilleur
buteur de l'histoire de l'équipe de
France on en parle dans un instant
d'abord on rejoint Vincent roseron sur
place Vincent votre impression après
cette rencontre il y a du monde derrière
vous parlez-nous de l'ambiance on a pas
vu une très grosse ambiance nous on n'a
pas entendu en tout cas à la télé ainsi
vous avez pas entendu alors là il y a un
super de l’arabie Saoudite qui vient me
voir a priori voilà donc les Saoudiens
qui ont gagné
qui ont gagné merci à vous alors au
niveau de l'ambiance et bah l'ambiance
est là surtout été française on n'a pas
entendu les Australiens quasiment pas en
tout cas mais on était sur une ambiance
quand même assez sympa très très loin de
l'Argentine Arabie Saoudite qu'on a eu
ce midi mais quand même pas mal
d'ambiance là vous voyez derrière moi
les supporters qui quittent le stade
petit à petit ça fait un petit moment
qui commence à quitter le stade mais
voilà c'est supporter qui partent et oui
l'ambiance en tout cas c'était assez
sympa
à suivre comme match sans vous avez des
supporters derrière vous est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en attraper en vol là pour
qu'il nous donne sa première réaction on
peut on peut essayer de on peut essayer
on peut je vais essayer de vous
rattraper quand je vois un maillot un
maillot français si j'arrive à en voir
si j'arrive en attraper parce qu'il
passe pas très bien alors normalement
moi je m'attendais à ce que les gens
avec une caméra vous savez les gens ils
viennent en général vous voir juste
derrière mais monsieur
on va essayer d'en trouver à tout à
l'heure en tout cas mais pour parler de
ce qui s'est passé au niveau de l'équipe
de France une équipe de France qui a la
mission est réussi voilà bah beaucoup
beaucoup encore de supporters
mais avec le drapeau français quand même
les drapeaux du livre comme vous pouvez
le voir on va essayer de trouver des
supporters français un peu plus tard en
tout cas bon j'ai bien aimé je vous
lance cette mission en tout cas vous
avez un superbe dodo j'aime beaucoup
quand vous nous montrez cette belle
chemise que vous arborez char Vincent
vous trouvez des supporters quand vous
voulez on aura les autres réactions de
nos journalistes qui sont sur place qui
écrivent les papiers à Baptiste des prés
Christophe remise vous les avez sur le
site dans quelques minutes et puis
demain évidemment dans le journal après
demain etc etc bon Olivier Giroud
forcément on revoit ce classement des
buteurs Olivier Giroud est tiré Henry
sont désormais qu'aux meilleurs buteur
de l'équipe de France il serait art
c'est quand même quelque chose ça oui
alors bien sûr c'est quelque chose c'est
tout à fait inattendu d'autant que c'est
un joueur qui n'a jamais été vraiment
considéré comme un titulaire de l'équipe
de France c'est un joueur il vous coupe
regardez Vincent Rozon il est sur place
il y a du monde autour de lui Vincent
allez-y
[Applaudissements]
oui vous l'entendez avec moi des
supporters alors attendez attendez on va
essayer de se calmer un peu qu'est-ce
que vous avez pensé de ce match
incroyable on a commencé avec une
blessure et un but contre nous ça nous a
pas forcément mis de l'ambiance dès le
début par contre on a vu que l'équipe de
Didier Deschamps est quand même une
équipe solide qui s'est rebondir qu'à
l'habitude des grands matchs qui est
présente dans cette compétition et on
espère faire un grand parcours on voit
que l'organisation est très belle on a
des très beaux stades on est très bien
reçu partout où on va et franchement
pour moi jusqu'à présent en tout cas
c'est une compétition qui va nous
apporter plein de surprises et on espère
une troisième coupe alors Olivier Giroud
aujourd'hui a égalé le record c'est
c'est comme superbe meilleur buteur de
l'équipe de France il est un juste
incroyable à son âge il a un talent
magnifique il sort de il sort un gros
match un doublé et c'était quand même
assez magnifique quand même de son côté
oh c'est un très très très gros match de
Olivier Giroud deux buts en espérant
qu'il en met un
52e but lors prochain match on va
essayer de regarder cet état d'esprit
défense on va améliorer un tout petit
peu la défense de l'équipe de France
deux jeunes
la charnière sont la charnière centrale
qui est pas assez expérimenté on l'a vu
ce soir qu'ils avaient des des qui
n'avaient pas vraiment des automatismes
mais bon ça va se régler au cours des ça
va se régler avec samedi le Danemark un
petit pronostic j'espère une victoire de
la France contre le Danemark pour
faciliter l'attache à la Tunisie qui a
juste à battre l'Australie
pour que le dernier plan dans les
calculs on est déjà dans les calculs car
nous on est des Tunisiens vivants en
tunisien on habite en France à Paris et
on espère vraiment pour que notre
plaisir soit parfait une qualification
de la France et de la Tunisie super
merci beaucoup messieurs merci à vous
voilà voilà pour ces supporters qui
rêvent d'avoir à la fois le côté de la
France et la Tunisie qui se qualifie
pour le Mondial pour la huitième
pays oui vive la France vous avez raison
vous nous rejoignez vous êtes devant le
stade pour certains avec Vincent roseron
sinon vous venez dans sur ce sur ce
plateau dans ce salon je salue gaelo IV
il vous salue eh voilà vous réagissez
sur YouTube sur le Le Figaro.fr on
parlait d'Olivier Giroud Vincent on a
parlé assez supporters on l'oublie vite
car une Benzema quand même Cédric non il
y a quelques jours on dirait
catastrophique il n'y a pas de Benzema
bon bah le même joueur évidemment mais
Giro plaît aux supporters français alors
je vais saluer le travail de nos
correspondants nous envoyer spéciaux
Qatar qui nous avait bien expliqué que
c'était pas la fin du monde sans Benzema
qui avait des solutions qui
effectivement il y avait Olivier Giroud
qui avait aussi tactiquement la
possibilité de jouer différemment et
puis bah là ce soir comme durant toute
sa carrière en équipe de France Olivier
Giroud a apporté une réponse
extraordinaire c'est vrai que de le voir
régaler leur corps de tirer Henry on
pouvait espérer sur un match comme ça
face à une opposition australienne que
moi je sentais fébrile derrière mais
c'est bien pour sa confiance et tout
parce qu'on est il est toujours
critiqué toujours remis en cause en même
temps il est toujours salué il a
vraiment un parcours en équipe de France
très paradoxal presque schizophrène et
c'est assez extraordinaire de voir ça
gaelo qui nous dit heureux de la
victoire à fou félicitations on parle
d'Olivier Giroud vous réagissez sur le
nouveau co meilleur buteur de l'histoire
de l'équipe de France il rejoint Thierry
Henri c'est pas rien Olivier Giroud
comment on le voit parce que vous êtes
vénézuélienne comment on le voit à
l'étranger le lieu où est-ce qu'on en
parle ou est-ce que bon c'est un joueur
lambda champion du monde
l'oublier au contraire par contre en
France effectivement les supporters il
est vraiment dans les corps des Français
plus que nous le pense parce que
vraiment il y a eu sur les réseaux
sociaux on n'est pas la vraie vie donc
voilà après c'est vrai qu'on venait cela
on suit énormément les équipes
espagnoles les clubs espagnols comme les
Barça et le Real Madrid il sait je vous
dis Real Madrid vous pensez directement
donc effectivement on parle le plus
peut-être des séjours là des Killian
Mbappe mais de manière générale la
France est vraiment un autre niveau
cette équipe de France plaît est-ce
qu'il n'était pas les cas avant à
l'étranger où on avait tendance à
percevoir l'équipe de France comme une
équipe un peu
un peu arrogante mais depuis qu'ils sont
champion du monde et c'est justement et
ce qui est Didier Deschamps a réussi à
créer c'est une équipe qui est soudée
mais qui est plaisante on les voit très
souriante très souvent donc en fait tous
ces choses là évidemment on jouait
beaucoup pour la communication qu'ils
ont à l'étranger bien sûr Vincent
roseron et sur place Vincent vous avez
suivi le match d'Olivier Giroud
attentivement vous en avez pensé quoi
vous depuis les tribunes
alors j'ai pas bien de votre question
parce que c'est le retour de
l'hélicoptère qui fait beaucoup de bruit
effectivement Olivier
efficace efficace ce match deux buts
voilà il a été il a été excellent on
aurait pu penser que l'égalisation
aurait du record de Thierry Henry
pouvait arriver sur cette retournée
acrobatique qui sortait vraiment
magnifique aussi et voilà il arrive à
faire ça il a été dans les bons coups on
l'attend pour finir pour marquer des
buts il est là et c'est ça qu'on lui
demande et il arrive à le faire et voilà
c'est c'est un très grand joueur de
l'équipe de France qui a réussi ce qu'on
lui demande c'est à dire marquer un
marquer des buts marqué ce doublé le
premier sur une superbe offrande
d'Adrien rabiot et deuxième sur une base
de Kylian Mbappe évidemment Vincent vous
nous retrouvez des supporters on aime
bien vous voir entouré de supporters de
l'équipe de France on parle encore un
peu d'Olivier Giroud vous continuez à
réagir vous êtes de plus en plus
nombreux à nous rejoindre sur le
Figaro.fr sur Youtube on discute
ensemble on débrief ensemble cette
rencontre France Australie quatre buts à
1 pour pour les Bleus
alors évidemment c'est peut-être trop
tôt pour en parler mais quelle place
gardera occupera Olivier Giroud dans
l'histoire de l'équipe de France
difficile d'en faire l'un des plus
grands joueurs des Bleus mais il force
de constater qu'il marquera non mais il
y a une espèce de il y a une espèce de
magie si vous voulez qui passe entre qui
transcende le jeu et qui passe entre
Olivier Giroud et le public en plus
c'est un garçon original quand on
connaît un peu c'est un garçon qui a la
foi qui en parle qui est à la fois
catholique qui a qui lit qui qui qui
aime bien la littérature
qui quand il s'exprime et toujours
souriant il est il est un peu atypique
quand même dans le paysage d'aujourd'hui
parce que
je dirais qu'il a il a des codes qui
sont anciens voilà c'est ça vous le
voyez un peu comme un joueur des années
80-90
un petit peu oui oui dans cet univers de
joueurs qui sont plutôt très jeunes très
très jeunes même plus ça va plus les
gens regardez la moyenne d'âge je sais
pas
l'équipe de France d'aujourd'hui
et lui il a 36 ans c'est rare pour un
joueur de champ donc avec Hugo Lloris il
représente
c'est Steve Mandanda et Hugo Lloris
depuis 2008 et lui il en équipe de
France depuis 2011 il représente une
certaine rencontre 2011 ça veut dire que
ça fait 20 ans
mais bon c'est difficile
ou
dinosaureau vous avez commencé avec les
vieilles gloire du foot mondial vous
continuez mais voilà il a une image il a
une place à part il a pas de place de
titulaire comme vous l'avez dit
indiscutable et c'est ça qui est très
étonnant c'est ça qui est très
remarquable contrairement à Thierry
Henry qui était intitulée indiscutable
qui a été le meilleur joueur de l'équipe
le meilleur buteur de l'équipe de France
Zidane indiscutable Platini indiscutable
Griezman
on peut aussi noter la très bonne
rentrée de théorlandaise à la place
qui est qui est pas sur décisif sur le
sur le but de rabiot et qui a beaucoup
apporté sur son côté
il y a beaucoup de
véritablement qu'une seule déception
c'est Benjamin Pavard je vous donne la
parole dans un instant mais d'abord je
lis de ce que nous dit Marie-Lou bravo
Giroud l'équipe de France a gagné même
sans Benzema nosditel je retrouve
Vincent roseron sur place il est avec un
supporter des Bleus Vincent
oui je suis avec deux supporters des
Bleus fadiles et Kamil Camille alors
vous avez pensé quoi de ce match de
l'équipe de France bah franchement
maîtriser du début à la fin on s'est
fait peur sur des heures du début sur
des erreurs on s'est fait pire sur des
erreurs mais dans l'ensemble on a quand
même bien gérer le match et vous vous
avez pensé quoi ah franchement super
déçu de la blessure de lucarlandaise on
sait pas non c'est pas exactement ce
qu'il a eu on va checker ça sur internet
mais c'est inquiétant pour la suite on
verra si l'ambiance est à la victoire
donc alors c'était cool alors on parlait
d'homme du match tout à l'heure l'homme
du match pour vous c'est qui
ça se joue bah oui bah paix c'est sûr
Giroud fait son rôle mais on parle pas
assez du rôle de Griezmann lors de la
rencontre il a vraiment joué un rôle clé
personnellement directement Giroud il a
mis son doublé alors que de base il
pensait pas être titulaire durant durant
cette Coupe du Monde il a répondu
j'arrive d'entrée sachant qu'en 2018 je
l'avais pas marqué donc là c'est super
cool ça part illégal en plus qui rit
est-ce que est-ce que c'est lui le plus
grand attaquant de l'équipe de France
aujourd'hui l'histoire de l'équipe de
France parce que numériquement c'est le
cas les stades c'est ça et les startups
et les stats le prouvent j'espère qu'ils
pourra durant cette compétition le
dépasser je lui souhaite pour lui la
France et vous si nous ramène une
dizaine Coupe du Monde il y aura plus de
bas je pense il y aura plus de vagues
super merci beaucoup à tous les deux
merci voilà c'est français qui étaient
très content de forcément avec avec une
victoire de l'équipe de France on vous
le rappelle 4h contre l'Australie et
Giroud homme du match pour pas d'Adrien
rabiot même si effectivement Adrien aura
bien nous on l'a senti dans le stade
quand même si sonne grâce à ses buts ça
sonne la révolte c'est vraiment
[Musique]
qui a des blessés effectivement on peut
s'inquiéter parce que c'est difficile à
remplacer mais là regardez quand il y a
des frères Hernandez qui parle l'autre
qui rentre bah c'est un meilleur match
en fait finalement quel autre donc
intéressant ce que je lis sur Le
Figaro.fr et sur Youtube Antoine Michel
très surpris du travail de Griezmann
très bon match il a très bien orienté le
jeu
Erwan bravo grisou alors les gens c'est
pas mon cas pour tout vous dire les gens
étaient épatés par Antoine Griezmann en
seconde période il a été beaucoup plus
convaincant il a il a commencé son match
dans leur des 10 dernières minutes de la
de la première période et en seconde
période quand la France a monopolisé le
ballon il y a eu beaucoup il y a eu un
une magnifique passe un moment donné sur
sur Killian Mbappé qui loupe son
contrôle mais
l'inspiration de Griezmann était
magnifique il a été voilà une première
mi-temps médiocre et une seconde très
convaincante de mon point de vue on
parle beaucoup de l'attaque Yves c'est
normal
s'intéressant est-ce que la défense a
été testée ce soir bah oui elle a été
testée en tous les cas on a vu ses
failles bavard n'a pas fait un grand
match bon la charnière centrale
on verra je dirais qu'elle a pas été
mise à grandes épreuve aussi il y a eu
les 20 premières minutes qui ont été
compliquées pour la France et puis en
deuxième mi-temps on se demandait même
si Loris avait couché le ballon
dans les arrêts de jeu mais donc il y a
pas il y a pas eu de match si vous
voulez au deuxième mi-temps il y a pas
la défense n'a pas eu un gros travail à
faire et c'est en première mi-temps ou
la santé mais je pense que cette
fidélité de première mi-temps était dû
au fait qu'il rentrait dans la
compétition qu'ils avaient qu'une peur
c'est effectivement de prendre un but
d'entrée ce qu'ils ont eu d'ailleurs et
puis après le but de rabiot les a un
petit peu libérés mais si c'est toujours
compliqué si vous êtes en plus ils sont
très jeunes les uns les autres
après par contre pour aller à l'encontre
de ce que disait de l'un des supporters
interrogés par Vincent vous allez à
l'encontre des supporters ils ont
toujours raison les supporters
hyper mécano et éconaté se connaissent
bien c'est à dire qu'ils étaient la
première fois qu'ils jouent ensemble en
équipe de France mais ils ont évolué
ensemble à l'Allemagne donc ils ont fait
une cinquantaine de matchs ensemble ils
ont font ils en ont fait cinq ensemble
en espoir donc ils se sont pas découvert
ce soir je lis ce que nous dit c'est
arrivé près de chez vous je sais pas si
près le Qatar excellent rabiot excellent
nous dit-il chacun il va son petit
commentaire bravo Mbappé nous dit Hans
tout le monde est content des joueurs
offensifs parlez-nous des joueurs
défensifs évidemment vous n'hésitez pas
cette défense on attend de l'avoir dans
d'autres contextes peut-être samedi
contre le Danemark sera plus difficile
effectivement et surtout quelle équipe
danois sur la connaît on l'a vu à Lolo
2021 comme il retrouve des forces
d'ailleurs ils ont vécu il faut les
rappeler une situation assez difficile
avec
Erickson qui avait souffert à l'escalia
qui ont commencé ils sont après ils ont
eu des fêtes mais ils sont réussis quand
même à se relever contre la Russie
contre les pays des gars donc vraiment
une équipe qui est puissante moi
vraiment la charnière centrale de
l'équipe de France mais rassurent
énormément il y avait un vrai doute par
rapport au fait que ou pas mécano a
effectivement qui est 14 sélections avec
l'équipe de France qu'on a également
donc il y avait ces doutes là mais je
trouve qu'ils font les gens
Varane non pardons pas banane Babar un
peu plus en difficulté mais il faut
aussi laisser les temps on va voir quels
sont les réactions ou les choix qui
peuvent être pris
le frère
sur le côté droit
il a fait son rôle de d'ascenseur et
magnifiquement enfin je veux dire et le
danger est beaucoup venu de la gauche
oui mais le danger je vais vous dire
pour moi ce que c'est Yves le danger
c'est qu'il n'y a plus qu'un seul
latéral gauche dans cette équipe de
France
d'accord mais
dans le temps je veux pas porter malheur
on peut on peut toujours s'arranger à
l'arrière je pense que c'est ce que
c'est ce que d'ailleurs des champs n'a
pas arrêté de faire finalement depuis
qu'il est sexionneur il a fait jouer des
latéraux au centre il a fait jouer des
centraux en latéral donc voilà
maintenant on va voir s'ils vont être
testés défensivement parce que sur ce
que j'ai vu cet après-midi du Danemark
et la Tunisie ça m'a quand même pas
ébloui sur le plan foncif alors le
Danemark le Danemark va pas abandonner
le ballon aux Français comme les
Australiens l'ont fait aujourd'hui ils
ont cette capacité à jouer avec Ericsson
avec le truc damsgard à construire et
tout mais
dans le Berg alors après il faut voir
parce que les Danois dans l'histoire
nous ont posé pas mal de problèmes
offensivement avec même des attaquants
qu'on s'attendait pas forcément à voir à
ce niveau là donc il faudra voir mais je
suis pas sûr que je sais pas si dans ce
premier tour on va vraiment être testé
défensivement on va retourner voir
Vincent roserand dans un instant nous
avons les images toujours devant ce
stade au Qatar où les Bleus viennent de
s'imposer quatre business vous continuez
à réagir c'est de nombreux sur YouTube
sur Le Figaro.fr bravo Didier Deschamps
ne surtout pas oublier le coach voilà ce
qu'on nous dit ivre je vais vous libérer
dans un instant merci est-ce que vous
êtes optimiste pour la suite de cette
compétition pour les Bleus oui ce que
j'ai vu là me donne un discours beaucoup
plus optimiste que celui que j'avais
avant le match parce que moi j'ai
toujours la crainte de ce premier tour
enfin de ce match de poule là qui sont
qui peuvent être en dormant d'ailleurs
enfin qui les petites équipes ont tout
intérêt à essayer d'étouffer les matchs
les y arrivent parfois mais là c'est pas
le cas le talent a quand même parlé
merci merci d'avoir passé la soirée avec
nous vous revenez quand vous voulez je
sais que vous êtes très pris que vous
avez une grosse journée demain au Figaro
évidemment et on vous retrouvera
peut-être pour les 8e de finale je sais
que vous serez là supporters des Bleus
Vincent Vincent roseron alors cette
défense
on en a parlé un peu en plateau vous
pour vous qu'est ce qu'elle vaut est-ce
qu'il faudra la revoir ou est-ce que
Raphaël Varane reviendra dans le 11 de
départ de Didier Deschamps notamment
contre le Danemark
alors c'est assez compliqué à prévoir
parce que Raphaël Varane c'est quand
même le patron de l'équipe de France
près de science élection c'est quand
même un homme de base de Didier
Deschamps il va pas être écarté comme ça
au moindre Pepper on l'a dit aussi
l'Australie c'est très faible quand même
il faut pas l'oublier on n'a pas vu à
part sur ce premier but à part sur cette
tête mais voilà à part ça on n'a pas vu
une grande équipe de Australie un
techniquement c'est assez limité voilà
c'était on était face à une équipe qui
était quand même assez moyenne et on
s'est fait peur après la charnière
centrale a été moi je trouve assez bonne
Konaté ou pas mécano ça fonctionne bien
on l'a dit il se connaissent depuis
l'Allemagne ça fonctionne bien ils sont
complémentaires ça marche bien Luc
Hernandez va falloir changer de toute
façon parce qu'a priori il est blessé on
ne connaît pas encore ce qu'il a mais ça
a pas l'air d'être ça a pas l'air d'être
bon pour samedi prochain ça c'est sûr et
Benjamin Pavard répare assurant du tout
Benjamin Pavard sur son côté vous l'avez
déjà dit mais dès le début du match il
monte ses faiblesses il oublie
complètement
au marquage vous l'avez dit à la
mi-temps il a complètement oublié au
marquage il marque le but et derrière il
fait pas non plus un grand match il a
pas été non plus extrêmement solide et
donc voilà Théo Hernandez de l'autre
côté qui alors vous êtes vous étiez en
train de le féliciter par rapport à tout
ce qu'il avait fait il a quand même fait
une perte de balle qui a fait écouter
assez cher aussi dès qu'il est rentré en
jeu mais après il a été très très bon je
voulais rebondir aussi sur une autre
chose c'est sur Kylian Mbappé parce que
tout à l'heure vous en parliez en tant
que du match Kylian Mbappe a été
excellent il a MP vraiment on a senti
que dès qu'il prenait le ballon il y
avait des étincelles alors le problème
c'est qu'au début on a senti qu'il a
voulu tout faire tout seul à un zéro
c'était on donne la balle à Mbappé se
dérouilles dans son coin mais après ça a
été un festival et dès qu'il a eu le
ballon sur le sur le côté il a enrhumé
son défenseur dans tous les sens ça a
été absolument impressionnant Mbappé il
marque de la tête ça fait combien de
temps qu'il avait pas marqué la date on
s'est demandé en tribune de presse on
n'avait pas le chiffre parce que voilà
Mbappe c'est pas un joueur de tête
normalement là il de la tête et une
petite mention aussi pour son compère de
l'autre côté moi et match moins
flamboyant bien évidemment mais Ousmane
Dembélé un peu solo dans dans ses
exploits mais pareil qui dès qu'il y a
eu le ballon ça ça faisait voilà ça
faisait des étincelles c'était
impressionnant
Ousmane Dembélé dans ses œuvres en tout
cas il a été enfin voilà il a ils ont
mis au supplice la défense australienne
en fait et au bout de 20 minutes ça peut
te dire mais sur tout un match ça ne
tient pas quand on a autant de qualité
technique que ça sur une attaque ça peut
pas ça ne peut pas tenir clairement et
les Australiens en ont fait les frais
ils pouvaient espérer un exploit mais
malheureusement ça n'a pas été le cas
reprenez votre souffle Vincent roseron
merci pour cette analyse globale je
reviens vers vous dans un instant si
vous retrouvez des supporters des gens
c'est avec plaisir c'est avec plaisir
Solène varie vous êtes de retour sur ce
plateau bonsoir merci
journaliste au service des réseaux
sociaux du Figaro comment ça s'est passé
ce match sur Twitter notamment j'imagine
qu'au début ça a dû être un peu tendu un
peu crispé dans certains tweets alors
oui au début forcément c'était très
crispé mais très vite nos internautes se
sont détendus et on a on retrouve en top
tweet évidemment tous les joueurs qui
ont fait vibrer les Français ce soir
donc en premier ils ont un sens
évidemment Olivier Giroud qui arrive
avec 51 buts en sélection à égaliser le
record de Thierry Henry donc ça c'est
vraiment ce qui revenait quasiment
systématiquement il est qualifié de
joueurs exceptionnel et réel en Phoenix
il a l'air quand même de consoler les
internautes de la perte de base
175000 tweets tendance dans la catégorie
de France pour Olivier Giroud je vois un
autre nom celui de Benjamin Pavard oui
oui Benjamin Pavard alors évidemment
ils ont parlé aussi de Benjamin Pavard
mais en effet je dirais que c'est
presque le seul qui se retrouve un peu
en top tweet et évoqué de façon plutôt
négative donc ils lui jette pas vraiment
de fleurs ils notent son
erreur au départ sur le premier but
australien donc ils ne l'ont pas
vraiment loupé Benjamin Pavard en
revanche celui qui les a surpris
agréablement c'est Adrien rabiot
beaucoup de trucs
forcément attendu sur ce match à ce
niveau là et donc on note beaucoup de
beaucoup de tweets élogieux à son égard
donc il surprend par la qualité de sa
performance et beaucoup ont tenté des
blagues sur la joie présumée de sa mère
puisqu'on sait que donc sa mère c'est
elle est extrêmement présente dans sa
carrière pour négocier son salaire et
donc
très présent on peut expliquer aux
internautes qui ne se connaissent pas
forcément Véronique rabiot le Paris
Saint-Germain c'est en quelque sorte
séparé un moment devrait un radio parce
que la maman était très très présente
avec la femme d'icardie pour ceux qui ne
la connais
ok au même ils ont du mal à saisir ces
rôles qui peuvent avoir certains mais
dans les cas de mélodiques on voit quand
aujourd'hui la carrière des raviaux en
équipe de France et puis même à la joue
Vincent le moment on peut pas on peut
pas trop lui faire des réponses non vous
avez raison parce qu'on a autre chose
je cherche pas tweet d'Emmanuel Macron
ni avant ni pendant ni après peut-être
qu'il le prépare il est certainement en
train de se poser
de lancement du truc d'Emmanuel Macron
donc autre blague qui est revenu à ces
systématiquement donc à propos d'Olivier
Giroud c'est sur son le fait que les
Giroud serait béni par le Saint-Esprit
puisqu'on sait qu'il n'a jamais fait
secret de sa foi de son de son
catholicisme très ancré et donc tous on
dit voilà Giroud il a été touché par la
grâce heureusement qu'il croit etc donc
ça c'est revenu de façon récurrente
voilà tout ce qu'on a tout ce qu'on a
remarqué ce soir en tout cas quand même
globalement beaucoup de beaucoup de joie
chez ces internautes après ce résultat
merci beaucoup Solène merci Cédric
allier de nous avoir accompagné une très
grande partie de la soirée on va faire
un petit changement de plateau on va
accueillir deux autres journalistes du
du service des sports je rejoins Vincent
roseron Vincent discutons un petit peu
tout les deux je vais vous lire les les
réactions de certains de nos internautes
il y a beaucoup de monde sur Youtube et
sur le Le Figaro.fr bravo Didier
Deschamps c'est ce que je lis plusieurs
fois descends il a fait des choix là ce
soir et des choix payants finalement
alors il a fait des choix payants mais
c'est des choix un peu contraints on se
rappelle c'est à dire que si on joue
c'est parce qu'il y a pas Benzema si ou
pas mécano est Konaté joue c'est parce
que varan n'est pas là donc c'est
chouette secours ont été bons il a fait
des bons choix de secours mais il les a
fait parce que il n'avait pas il a pas
d'autre choix ah attendez j'ai
insupporteur je pense mais alors c'est
un support avec mauvais drapeaux avec
les drapeaux du Maroc attendez
messieurs messieurs
voilà
en France
voilà comme vous pouvez le voir il y a
beaucoup de en tout cassure cette
expérience alors vous voyez c'est en
train de se vider c'était les derniers
supporters je pense qui arrive
maintenant au compte-goutte avec avec
des supporters avec des supporters
marocains comme vous le disez votre
question j'ai une question à priori
est-ce que vous m'entendez ouais oui
j'ai l'impression que vous avez beaucoup
de supporters
saoudien
tunisien même marocain et alors qu'ils
ne sont pas la Coupe du monde si je ne
m'abuse des Marocains
ils sont pas la Coupe du Monde pardon
pour mon mon erreur il y a beaucoup en
fait les stades sont remplis par des
supporters d'autres nations dans ce que
je vois là non
oui alors pas mal après effectivement il
y a beaucoup de gens attendez on va on
va essayer d'avoir une interview avec un
supporter assez connu de l'équipe de
France je pense attendez on va essayer
de le faire venir regarder qui me
rejoint s'il veut bien Clément dentier
bonjour Clément comment allez-vous ça va
qu'est-ce que vous avez pensé de ce
match Clément
la souffler un peu au départ puis après
ça c'est
décanté
donc au départ ça surprend un peu de se
faire prendre ce petit but là et puis on
a déroulé c'est c'est tout logiquement
c'est imposé quoi oui parce que l'équipe
d'Australie c'était quand même assez
faible on va le dire et oui mais vu
le spectacle navrant qu'on a eu avec le
avec
l'Argentine ainsi dit c'est mal barré
cette histoire là puis si c'est bon ça
s'est bien passé quoi c'est
logique quoi il y a deux buts super
retourné de notre ami Giroud ça a pas
marché c'est dommage ça aurait été
magnifique je garderai ce geste là très
bien merci beaucoup je crois qu'on vous
appelle pour pour repartir mais merci en
tout cas
d'avoir été avec nous
euh alors peut-être qu'il va partir on
ne sait pas partir ou pas alors il est
plus que c'était il a son stock
normalement Clément dentiste il est pas
avec lui alors
[Musique]
petit
on est lui le micro Vincent allez-y il
s'en va clémentines
alors normalement il me pose des
questions sur l'organisation le le
centre média est vers là-bas
voilà je il fallait l'aider voilà
c'était Clément d'Antibes supporters
connus qui n'avait pas
comment s'appelle son coq déjà vous le
savez vous en plateau non Vincent vous
savez ouais voilà c'est ça la réponse
vous avez raison merci Vincent ça me
fait plaisir que vous ayez vu Clément
anti venus me demander si le supporter
le plus emblématique des blocs était au
Qatar et bien visiblement il y est on
revient vers vous dans un instant
Vincent j'ai accueille te dit va
dévalous merci d'être ici journaliste au
service des des sports du Figaro bon
comment on a eu des réactions de ces
deux-là je veux la vôtre à votre avis
générale ça vous a plu ça m'a plu après
cette victoire de de ce soir elle
ressemble pas trop aux équipes de
d'échanges je trouve
je trouve que c'est un continuité de
l'euro 2020 c'est-à-dire
des champs a toujours
aligné des équipes très organisées avec
un le blog défensif très très compact et
là on a vu tout le contraire on a vu une
équipe qui avait un allon offensif qui a
qui a marqué beaucoup de buts et c'est
pas ce qui a fait la marque de fabrique
de de l'air des champs depuis le depuis
le début et je sais pas si c'est voué à
continuer à amener l'équipe de France
assez loin sans une base solide et j'ai
trouvé qu'il y avait quand même pas mal
de je pense que vous en avez parlé mais
beaucoup de manque sur les côtés et en
défense centrale je lis quelques-uns des
commentaires que nous avons sur Le
Figaro.fr d'abord Giroud rabiot
Hernandez c'est aussi un peu la victoire
de l'Italie oui et tout ces joueurs qui
jouent en Italie c'est un mais
intéressant cette remarque Cédric parce
que le championnat italien avait perdu
un peu de sa superbe la cote du
championnat italien était moins
importante depuis une dizaine d'années
là c'est pas tout à fait faux les trois
meilleurs joueurs de ce soir
peut-être selon nous en tout cas rabiot
Hernandez Giroud joue en Italie oui
alors c'est ça reste la vérité d'un soir
italien je suis désolé je vais peut-être
blesser certains de mes amis transalpins
mais ça reste quand même on les voit
avec les résultats de la Juventus bon en
Ligue des Champions c'est quand même pas
extraordinaire attention on va saluer
nappe mais bon il y a pas de joueurs
français à Naples en équipe de France
donc non non il faut voir pour pour
rebondir sur ce que sur ce que dit là il
y a une question alors
Thibault vous allez adorer ça mais c'est
de la technique au tactique mais après
je prends des notes allez-y donc on peut
se poser la question n'a parlé tout à
l'heure donc je suis désolé je vais
aller à l'encon de ce que vous allez
dire mais est-ce qu'il faut pas et vous
lui répondre c'est pas faire est-ce
qu'il faut revenir donc à une défense à
trois ah 300 trop oh là ça y est on est
dans le il est quelle heure 22h38
on va tout vous expliquer je vous
laisserai pas au bord de la touche donc
moi je mettrai 300 trop sur
malheureusement je sanctionnerai pas
voir pour son mauvais match je mettrais
Kingsley coman en piston donc vous
mettrez un joueur très offensif en mais
pas en latéral sur défenses
qui a déjà joué plusieurs fois piston
récemment en équipe de France et Théo
hollandaise qui a l'habitude plus ou
moins de ce rôle au Milan AC et voilà et
donc je mettrai un troisième centrale
qui pourrait être Varane ce qui
laisserait eu par mécano et qu'on a été
allez-y ma chère signaler un commentaire
je vous donne la parole Raphaël qui nous
dit Varane un peu trop faible vous
trouvez pas il a l'air d'être d'accord
avec vous on n'est pas marrante en fait
pour moi ce qui est important pourquoi
c'est important de garder une défense à
quatre même si je pense que les systèmes
à avoir tendance à évoluer mais plutôt
en 4-3 mais parce que une défense à
quatre quand vous avez deux droitiers
comme ou pas mécano et Konaté mais qui
arrive aussi à jouer à ses postes ça ne
gêne pas dans une défense à quatre mais
si vous êtes dans une défense à toi ça
peut être un peu plus compliqué et puis
il faut faut pas oublier que la France
risque de tomber peut-être ou pas parce
qu'on a vu que l'Argentine ça n'a pas
été brillant mais avec des équipes comme
les brésiles ou l'Argentine notamment
l'Argentine qui craint c'est défenseurs
costaud que nous avons en équipe de
France et d'ailleurs même dans les
nations européennes parce qu'ils n'ont
pas l'habitude de les confronter donc je
pense qu'une défense au solide face à
ces nations là c'est vraiment ce qu'il
faut donc je reste sur la défense à 4
vous tranchez cette cette bataille au
sommet attention vous venez d'arriver ne
vous fâchez pas avec mes amis avec
Cédric plusieurs plusieurs fois depuis
15 ans donc c'est pas très grave non
mais je suis pas forcément d'accord
parce que la défense A3 a pas forcément
donné dégage de sécurité quand il l'a
aligné et je serai plus partant dans
quatre trois à renforçant le milieu de
terrain parce que je trouvais que
rabiothewamini était un peu plus un peu
un peu isolé et puis ça permettrait
d'avoir trois jours le problème c'est
que
ça va ça va décaler Griezmann sur le
côté droit ça va enlever Dembélé qui
était très bon tout à l'heure bon c'est
pas d'autre c'est pas de souci
dans la liste il y en a pas beaucoup
donc s'il y a un blessé derrière bon
Jordan vero avec tous les produits
Griezmann ou Dembélé
je peux le faire rentrer en cours de
match parce que je sais qu'il pourrait
apporter voilà quand une défense est
fatiguée pour apporter du de l'énergie
et Griezmann alors oui côté le décalé
c'est pas forcément lui rendre service
mais voilà je partirai de ce principal
mais Deschamps à la dire en confiance de
presse avant la Coupe du monde que il
voyait pas il se voyait pas aller loin
avec quatre éléments offensifs
strictement offensifie là il a jamais à
henné vraiment quatre éléments c'est
vrai que c'est rare ce qui vient de
faire ce soir en 2018 le quatrième
milieu c'est un milieu défensif qui a
été décalé qui a été Matuidi donc
rabiot doit poser plus encore il en est
capable il faut qu'il s'en persuade
c'est peut-être une solution ça mettre
radio en meneur de jeu mais en joueur
plus offensif on voit qu'il est capable
de se projeter de jouer de la tête de
percutant il l'a fait là ce soir
oui mais parce qu'ils étaient dans cette
condition-là parce qu'il faut pas
oublier questionner dans ces systèmes
c'est parce qu'il y a eu des blessés en
équipe de France moi je pense que c'est
plutôt Griezmann qui devait être amener
à descendre un petit peu plus parce
qu'effectivement qu'on voulait dit tu as
du stotitre les milieux étaient un petit
peu isolés et et c'est là où moi je
pense où ils sont peinés les plus parce
que la charnière centrale la défense je
la trouvais bien enfin après il faut
voir effectivement les équipes les
adversaires ne se ressembleront pas il y
a des équipes qui vont être beaucoup
plus offensives là où on était plus dans
une équipe qui jouait beaucoup à faire
des passes et un peu à patienter
peut-être l'équipe de France donc il
faut voir est-ce que ça donne par la
suite la défense a-t-elle été vraiment
testé ce soir Teddy non bah non on a vu
la faible adversité
9 sélections à eux deux bon j'étais un
peu fébrile pour tout vous dire je vois
les 10 premières minutes je me dis aïe
aïe donc on peut pas maintenant on peut
pas dire qu'elle était testé mais même
en étant pas testé je les ai trouvés
enfin je les ai trouvés fébrile à la
relance surtout et notamment Konaté ou
pas mécano je l'ai bien aimé son jeu
long voilà j'ai trouvé qu'il avait un
bon jeu long les transversales il
arrivait à renverser il était très très
bon il a renversé la défense adverse
grâce à ces changements qui ont permis
de d'écarter mais Konaté je l'ai pas
trouvé très serein ball aux pieds donc
il nous faut quand même des bons
relanceurs mais après bon là encore
c'est la patte de Didier Deschamps il a
l'habitude de préférer des défenseurs
plutôt robustes que des défenseurs qui
avancent bien j'espère que Hernandez je
vous coupe je lis ce que me dit Julien
blanc j'espère qu'ernandez va s'en
remettre parce qu'il est complètement
indispensable à l'équipe de France
depuis des années maintenant vous voyez
cette image de Luca Hernandez et vous
voyez la réaction Didier Deschamps s'est
en conférence de presse je la découvre
avec vous cela me semble assez grave
c'est le gros point noir de la soirée de
ce soir
à notre côté positif c'est peut-être moi
qui suis optimiste mais il y en a pas eu
plus de jeux à blessés et on aurait pu
s'y attendre c'est sûr avec un optimisme
pareil nous sommes champions du monde je
signe tout de suite comme ils ont joué à
un moment on s'est dit c'est pénale mais
heureusement que l'arbitré là parce que
de l'équipe australienne qui joue en
Bundesliga il était quand même parfois
un petit peu agressif donc il faut aussi
préserver nos jus même si on a une bonne
profondeur des banques faut pas oublier
qu'on en a quand même pas mal d'accès
c'est pas gagné parce que les Danois
physiquement c'est assez costaud et puis
les Tunisiens pour pour avoir vu le
match récemment France Tunisie au parc
c'était
ça y va aussi ça ça
renvoie du lourdisons l'avantage en plus
de jouer dans des stades qui connaissent
voilà et beaucoup beaucoup évoluent au
Qatar avec donc voilà il y a c'est pas
gagné d'avance 22h45 nous sommes en
stand une dizaine de minutes les Bleus
ce sont imposés ce soir quatre buzza 1
pour leur entrée en lice dans cette
Coupe du Monde 2022 vous découvrez le
classement si vous nous rejoignez
l'équipe de France prend donc la tête de
son groupe l'Australie étant dernière
position évidemment et puis il Danemark
le Danemark il a Tunisie ferraille pour
l'instant pour accrocher cette deuxième
place il reste encore deux matchs pour
chaque équipe tout n'est pas fait mais
la France prend déjà une belle option on
sait qu'une victoire dans un groupe A4
en trois matchs ça donne de belles
perspectives les amis là bah surtout
avec le match nul entre le Danemark et
la Tunisie là on a on a on a un match
samedi contre les Danois qui est clair
si on gagne ce match 1 en est qualifié
de vous être sûr alors si la France
j'aime bien sortir la calculette je
pense que ça intéresse nos internautes
mettons qu'on gagne contre le Danemark
oui
ensuite la Tunisie l'Australie en cas de
match nul vous aurez même la France qui
sera non seulement qualifié mais
certaines de finir la Tunisie aurait
deux points l'Australie un point donc si
la Tunisie Balos Australie la Tunisie
donc on est aussi qualifié avec 6 points
d'être premier mais on est certain
qualifié exactement et si l'Australie
gagne vu qu'on a battu l'Australie alors
ça je crois que c'est toujours le et de
toute façon les deux autres ça resteront
à un point donc ça sera non quoi qu'il
arrive si on balle et danois on est sûr
d'être qualifié et on a même de très
très belles perspectives d'assurer la
première place donc de pouvoir tourner
vous avez c'est pour ça que vous avez
disparu de ce live pendant une dizaine
de minutes vous étiez en train de
calculer non j'étais très fort en maths
au collège vous la racontez un petit peu
on regarde ce que nous dit Baptiste des
prés peut-être ouh là c'est tout petit
alors moi j'arrive pas à lire je vais
retrouver ce qu'il a dit parce que j'ai
sur le portable ce qui nous a envoyé
alors je remonte Baptiste des prêts
Hernandez on sonné la révolte les
Australiens beaux joueurs ont conférence
de presse voilà ce qui nous dit on a
fait ce qu'on a pu mais l'équipe de
France était largement au-dessus voilà
ce qui nous dit je le lis quand on voit
les difficultés du Danemark et de
l'Argentine c'est toujours dur de
rentrer dans un mondial avec la dans la
peau avec la peau de favoris pour ça il
faut saluer le sérieux des bleus et
aussi l'immense limite de l'Australie
merci au soccerwood oui c'est le nom des
Australiens et ça fait presque du bien
lui Baptiste nous dit on a bien fait de
jouer contre ces Australiens ça nous
rassure oui mais alors je sais pas je
vais passer pour un pessimiste mais
alors oui vous êtes le côté vous êtes le
temps négatif et vous êtes positif
c'est bien de débuter
débuter une compétition par une victoire
mais ça ça n'engage pas la suite de la
compétition quoi donc le plus important
je pense que ça va être de tenir
physiquement
et j'ai envie de voir le niveau physique
de de l'équipe de France tout au long de
cette compétition je me rappelle qu'en
2014 on avait gagné on avait cartonné
contre l'équateur je crois
d'entrée et je et progressivement on
avait c'était pas le Honduras non du
reste mais vous avez raison voilà et
après on avait décliné je trouve
physiquement pour finir sur les rotules
contre l'Allemagne en étant éliminé donc
attendant de voir mais je trouve que
c'était bon et même nécessaire pour la
morale alors peut-être pas pour les
cadres Kyo on l'habitude des journaux et
des réactions mais peut-être plus pour
les jeunes je me rappelle très bien de
la façon dont on parlait des hoopa
mécano comme quelqu'un qui ne serait pas
à la hauteur d'être dans ce niveau-là et
regarder comment il apporte à l'équipe
de France donc je pense que c'est bon
pour la confiance des rentrées de cette
manière surtout quand on voit par
exemple une équipe comme l'Argentine je
suis désolée de en parler à nouveau mais
qui tombe ça nous les soudains
américains on y était pour et qui tombe
face à une équipe donc voilà il faut pas
non plus cacher son bonheur vivons cette
soirée avec beaucoup de bonheurs je
pense que la Coupe du Monde est très
bien lancée pour la France
qui a dit d'ailleurs tout pas mécano le
défenseur de l'équipe de France à propos
d'Olivier Giroud il est très important
pour nous c'est un leader on en a
toujours besoin on va voir si on peut
retrouver Vincent roseron sur place j'ai
l'impression qu'il y a plus grand monde
autour du stade mais j'aimerais bien le
voir je veux en profiter il est il est
presque une heure du matin
Vincent ah oui vous êtes là vous êtes
bien seul dites-moi ça effectivement les
stades et ben oui regardez il y a pas
grand mais attendez regardez je vais
vous montrer je vais tourner un petit
peu la caméra si ça marche bien et je
vais vous montrer un petit groupe de
supporters qui est là-bas
qui continue de faire la fête un peu
plus loin je vais vous zoomer en
essayant de il chante il chante pour
Giraud en tout cas alors je sais que la
caméra est sur un pied oh il y a Obélix
allez-y est-ce que vous pouvez prendre
la caméra vous allez avec eux je sais
pas si vous allez vous faire voler le
pied peut-être pas oh là là
excusez-moi mais je ne suis pas aussi
mobile que ça ça vous avez le support
vous avez une un coq vous avez
ce qu'on va faire je vous laisse une
petite minute
je vais essayer de les chercher allez-y
allez-y merci à tout de suite je ne
passerai pas à côté de l'interview de
belix mon cher ami vous continuez à
réagir sur le Figaro.fr sur sur Youtube
vous avez pas parlé d'Olivier Giraud mon
cher atelier on en a beaucoup parlé au
début au moment historique là pour
l'histoire de l'équipe de France hein
[Musique]
j'ai bien compris c'est par rapport à
Giroud je trouve qu'il est je pense
qu'il libérer de l'absence de Benzema et
j'ai l'impression en tout cas que bah
voilà je le vois plus épanoui alors je
sais pas c'est peut-être un hasard mais
je le vois plus épanoui en plus je vois
que les les coéquipiers sont
contemporels on a vu Mbappé super
content alors qu'il a quand même la
réputation d'être un peu égoïste et
voilà je l'ai trouvé je l'ai trouvé bien
il est il va être déterminant dans cette
Coupe du Monde c'est évident et il y en
a un qui est tombé dedans quand il était
petit il est avec Vincent roserand
effectivement je suis avec Hotmail
Obélix ce magnifique déguisement on vous
voit avec un petit coq aussi qui se
balade là-bas vous avez forcé quoi de ce
match Hotman alors il y a eu deux matchs
en un dire il y a eu les 20 premières
minutes avec le but australien la
blessure de Lucas Hernandez on s'est dit
on va rentrer dans 10 jours et après il
y a eu un après 35 minutes quatre buts
t'as jamais vu ça je pense que c'est le
meilleur c'est le meilleur départ en
face de groupe dans un championnat
depuis très longtemps avec une blessure
quand même avec une blessure avec du
Beaujeu et en plus avec toutes les avec
toute la succession de blessures qu'on a
eu avant on pensait le groupe impacter
on pensait encore des champions du monde
qui sortaient au premier tour et au
final grosse surprise on est tous très
contents le match c'est terminé depuis
bientôt une heure on est encore là elle
voit ça
vous mettez bien l'ambiance oui c'est
pas mal c'est un petit groupe bien sympa
comment vous avez trouvé d'ailleurs
l'ambiance dans le stade c'était quand
même sympa ben nous on était rassemblés
donc entre nous euh c'était pas mal
après je pense que avec le scénario du
match il y a eu beaucoup beaucoup
d'intensité et du coup ça a aidé aussi
c'était pas comme les matchs de
l'après-midi ou il y avait pas beaucoup
d'enjeux c'était bien fermé là ça
arrêtait pas d'attaquer je pense que les
gens n'ont rien lâché aussi ça nous a
permis aussi de ne rien lâcher on est
resté jusqu'au bois les supporter
un petit MV un peu petit joueur meilleur
joueur
bah je dirais voyageru parce qu'il
rentre dans l'histoire illégalystérie
Henry je pense que il y a 5 ans 5 ans
personne n'aurait pas rester là après
Mbappe qui rejoue collectif et c'est
aussi bon à prendre pour l'équipe de
France
on l'a vu au début de match être un peu
soliste mais parce que on a l'impression
que c'est un peu la stratégie française
et après il a vraiment montré toute sa
classe lors de ce match là une passe d
un but impliqué sur pas mal de
d'occasions dangereuses c'était pas mal
je pense qu'il a même été élu homme du
match si je me trompe pas donc voilà
c'est c'est bon pour la suite et vous
vous restez au Qatar pour continuer de
suivre l'équipe de France je reste
jusqu'à l'élimination jusqu'à
l'élimination ou la toit jusqu'à la
troisième étoile et ben on va faire on
va souhaiter ça merci beaucoup Othman
d'avoir été avec la merci beaucoup
voilà Thibault pour Obélix qui était
avec nous donc qui nous a donné un peu
ces de ce qu'il pensait de ce match et
de l'ambiance il est en train de
rejoindre en courant
vous le voyez derrière moi ça commence à
se vider complètement
irréductible Gaulois qui restera
jusqu'au bout Vincent j'ai un dernier
défi parce qu'on va rendre l'antenne
d'ici quelques minutes j'ai vu une poule
j'ai vu un supporter déguisé en poule ah
oui il est peut-être parti alors
malheureusement elle est partie très
elle est partie là je peux pas laisser
le bataille ici et partir à l'autre bout
du stade parce que la personne est
partie bon ça court vite effectivement
magnifique déguisement il fallait
choisir entre la poule et Obélix vous
aviez pas eu la poule de Clément
d'Antibes vous aviez eu on a vu la poule
déguisée visiblement aux abords du stade
bon on reste avec vous encore une petite
seconde je reviendrai une dernière fois
vers vous Vincent bon un petit top 3
messieurs dames Cindy je commence avec
vous top 3 des des choses à retenir de
ce match pour vous pas forcément positif
on peut avoir du négatif aussi
alors non mais on positif je pense que
ce qui ressort les mieux mais surtout
quand on fait une bonne entente parce
que tous les mêmes ils ont fait une
bonne entame il faut quand même appeler
rester assez régulier et c'est ça que je
n'ai pas forcément apprécié parce que
effectivement la première mi-temps ne
ressemble pas du tout à la deuxième
mi-temps heureusement que ils se sont un
peu réveillé donc j'aimerais qui est
toujours cette grande envie de l'équipe
de France qu'on peut voir parfois dans
un autre sélection et qu'on a vu
d'ailleurs dans l'équipe de France de
2018 parce que c'est ça qui les a fait
gagner et aussi on attend les histoires
comme il y a peu à voir avec Ali Rami
avec les Centaures voilà tous ces
histoires des groupes qui font aussi que
de toute façon les football c'est aussi
une fête donc on a envie d'avoir une
groupe souder et être vraiment plaisant
pour tous ces histoires Cédric votre top
3 des choses à retenir sur cette
rencontre le record d'Olivier Giroud est
galet ça c'est une certitude la blessure
de Lucas Hernandez et puis
et puis
l'excellente performance de de rabiot
bon vous êtes le dernier mais vous
pouvez dire la même chose
parce que c'est lui qui a un peu
réveillé l'équipe de France qui était un
peu endormi en début de match donc je
trouve que plus que Mbappé qui a été élu
homme du match je trouve que rabiot est
quand même l'homme du match parce que on
l'avait passé qui a été élu du match
vous écoutez
vous me provoquez vous venez sur la
dernière demi-heure moi je suis là
depuis 19h je suis d'accord bon oui
non
Rabiou qui a révélé l'équipe voilà avec
son pressing oh enfin voilà je pense que
vous en avez parlé oui la blessure de
location en anglais ce qui enlève je
pense qu'il va être absent il va être
forfait pour le reste de la compétition
je pense puisque des champs a dit que
c'était assez grave
la réaction Didier Deschamps conférence
de presse là me semble assez grave c'est
le gros point noir de ce soir c'est ça
reste une solution en moins pour le bon
si tu après ça veut dire que tu es
Hernandez va faire toute la compétition
à ce poste de latéral gauche donc ça
laisse des ça laisse pas de munition
pour Didier Deschamps en défense et
troisième
Mbappé j'ai beaucoup aimé sa façon de
provoquer et je trouve que Mbappé
Dembélé voilà les ailes les ailes ont
bien fonctionné
il y a eu je sais pas combien de centres
d'ailleurs je sais pas si on a la stats
mais mais beaucoup de centres pour
Giroud et franchement je trouve que les
deux ont bien percuté chacun de leur
côté je lui laisse ouais
finalement cette première place et la
voix des 8e de finale qui s'est ouvert
considérablement je lui laisse le mot de
la fin Vincent roseron on parle des du
top 3 des choses à retenir ce soir
remettez-vous devant la caméra Vincent
que retenez-vous de cette soirée vous
qui étiez au stade au Qatar
et ben d'abord on peut quand même
retenir la victoire de la France je
pense parce que quand même on a réussi
notre rentrée ce qui est pas le cas de
toutes les nations bon on a voilà de
rien merci le score d'aval c'est quand
même important c'est que la première
chose à savoir vous devrez le savoir non
plus plus sérieusement en plus
sérieusement la blessure de Lucas
Hernandez effectivement qui est quand
même parce que on avait dit qu'on allait
gagner contre qu'on allait gagner et que
voilà la France devait gagner que
l'Australie c'est chose faite mais on a
quand même perdu l'occasion irlandaise
et après ce que je retiendrai je sais
pas trop effectivement le réveil
d'Adrien raviaux qui a enfin le la
performance d'un radio qui a permis le
réveil et moi j'ai trouvé que la
charnière centrale a plutôt fait un bon
match donc du coup
cette charnières centrale qui fonctionne
bien face à on l'a on l'a dit à une
équipe assez faible quand même
tout ça c'est grâce à lui ce plateau et
puis également les réseaux sociaux du
Figaro parce qu'il nous aide à vous
répondre sur les différents tchats sur
YouTube sur Le Figaro.fr et je remercie
Solène varie d'ailleurs qui est venu
tout à l'heure sur plateau pour venir
nous dire ce qu'il se disait sur les
réseaux sociaux bravo à l'équipe de
France victoire 4 buts à 1 on va
profiter un peu et puis on se remet vite
dans le bain parce que samedi il y a un
autre match ce sera face au Danemark
merci de nous avoir suivi excellente
soirée sur le figure en live